this can't happen again rob trade russ
maybe a pig and we get kuzma and kcp
what
yeah i'm
done rob i know make the trade run
the arena outside of space and time
welcome the king lebron james finally me
and him i can't wait to compare space
jams to our first two or two portal
match-ups oh whoa whoa whoa whoa two on
two but kd got his
oh yes i like this because i'm a good
teammate
[Applause]
and me nba all-star penny hardaway all
right let's destroy this old man
whatever man at least i get to play with
hey lebron it's me a.d oh come on he's
not even my best sidekick penny's not
jack's best either
what i'm no sidekick y'all know the deal
play to 11 win by two i'll check penny
man if you don't get your lanky ass down
in the paint and guard shaq
barbecue chicken
damn did that hurt use portal crane the
only interdimensional
[Applause]
ointment in the
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey i need you to step your game up my
legacy can't afford a portal loss
oh
you see that lebron i did good right
tax is complicated because you sometimes
work in space try shack tax isn't that
right little penny man i am regular
penny the puppet is at six [ __ ] seven
look i don't want us ending up like
those two if we cool why'd you go to
disney world without me because you
can't fit on the rides so if you don't
want to play as a big man that's fine
just be yourself as long as it means me
getting a win
you might be superman in the paint but
your kazam on the
[Applause]
you know perimeter at times like this i
worry about the 1990s orlando magic
dynasty yo
thanks
[Applause]
[Applause]
tons of media opportunities i have one
eyebrow when i keep getting offers later
penny i'm going with them
shacky son of a
wow i am a team player
[Music]
you